Land und Brecht
[Musik]
Richard Sommer in Hamburg und wir hier
freu mich ja und Maria
das ist regnet in Hamburg freut leicht
freue ich mich über regen weil auch und
wo auch immer ja absolut das ist so
verrückt ne wenn ich ich habe neulich
mit mit einem großartigen Hydrologen mit
einem Borchardt darüber gesprochen
Professor Borchert der sagte was ich
dafür paradigment verändert haben ne die
meine wir haben Jahrzehnte lang alles
gebaut gemacht Drainagen Ableitungen
Regenrohre und so weiter um Wasserlos zu
werden und plötzlich müssen wir das
ganze nur denken plötzlich müssen wir
anfangen zu überlegen wie sammeln wir
was aber wie kriegen wir das so verteilt
dass es funktioniert und es fehlen
komplett anderthalb Jahre Wasser im
Boden ja anderthalb Jahre also
anderthalb ich habe ihn extra noch mal
gefragt anderthalb Jahre jeden Tag Regen
genau das ist das was uns ist das was
was fehlt und besonders übel im Osten
genau Brandenburg weil weil wir haben ja
dann da hier in Berlin rum und so diesen
märkischen Sand und Sandboden speichert
das Wasser nicht richtig genau über
Wasser sollten wir noch mal eine eigene
Folge machen vor allem wenn du hörst das
Wasser ich glaube immer april kamen in
Berlin ungefähr vier Wasserkästen Wasser
runter ja pro Quadratmeter
ein Monat später waren es vier Gläser
und dann quasi nichts mehr das ist die
Situation das ist total krass aber
Richard ich habe ich wollte eigentlich
mit dir was ganz anderes reden und da
kam mir heute morgen etwas unter und ich
dachte also das ist doch das Thema
überhaupt für den so Direktor meines
Herzens Gefühl für dich es kann die
schöne Meldung und deswegen würde ich so
gerne mit dir über Biodiversität und
Arten und Artenvielfalt sprechen in
Australien ist ein kleiner Drache wieder
entdeckt worden ein ohrloser Drache der
und das fand ich so schön 1969 das
letzte Mal gesehen wurde tot erklärt
wurde 1969 bin ich auf die Welt gekommen
und ich dachte nicht dass er sich
meinetwegen versteckt hat verschenken
möglicherweise gibt es da keinen
Zusammenhang aber ist noch nicht
bewiesen also der ist schon offiziell so
lange von der Welt Weg wie du auf der
Welt drauf und bei dir wahrscheinlich
dein Leben sehr lang vorkommt
historischen Zeitalter gesehen ist ist
natürlich eine Sensation 69 wenn du
sowas liest freue ich mich freust du
dich freue ich mich und gleichzeitig tut
er mir leid weil ich denke na ja einen
zu finden hilft dich jetzt werden
natürlich Reptilien alt aber auch nicht
so alt und vor allem ist er auch immer
so klein ne
groß und da gesagt ist ja vier
verschiedene Arten geben jetzt geht die
große Sucherei los mit Hunden
ich denke mal was sind das für Hunde ne
die die nicht fressen die verstehen aber
die dessen Duft irgendwie ich weiß nicht
richtig ja ja ja das ist schon eine
große Leistung aber ist irgendwie eine
schöne Meldung also ähm ja immer noch
gehofft der wollte Wolf würde irgendwann
wiedergefunden wer ist das der Beutel
Wolf der Beutelwolf lebte in Tasmanien
ah ja ja ja und war das größte
fleischfressende Beutel hier ungefähr so
groß wie mittelgroßer Hund und der hat
auf dem Rücken so eine braune gelbe
Zeichnung
okay und sage ich ja völlig verrückt aus
und er hatte die das eigentlich aus wie
ein Hund aber denn er sein Maul
aufsperrte dann konnte das zu 180 Grad
aufmachen also wie eine Schlange quasi
wirklich
so weit aufreißen super ja und der
letzte ist in 30er Jahren im Zoo
gestorben und dann hat die zoologische
Gesellschaft in New York oder in
Washington oder sowas die haben einen
Preis ausgesetzt also wer noch mal
einsichtet und seitdem gehen Jahrzehnten
für Jahrzehnt neue Spuren und so weiter
ja
Tasmanien aber
wo auch immer das hochkommando dann
guckt der stellt sich das da mehr oder
weniger als Fake raus ist aber noch
nicht zu spät wie wir haben am Beispiel
des ohrlosen kleinen Drachen hinter sich
richtig das stimmt aber die
Wahrscheinlichkeit sind hier dieser
Größe aber man weiß es nicht es gibt
große Tiere die sehr spät entdeckt
wurden ja es gibt es gibt ja ich habe
das in der Vorbereitung mir angeguckt
erstaunlich wenig Säugetiere große Tiere
also Tiere von jemand sagen würde die
kann man nicht so leicht übersehen 5000
Arten ungefähr also 6000 oder 6000
Säugetiere und die wird Abstand größte
Gruppe der Säugetiere sind Fledermäuse
wenn die die mal rausrechnen ist dann
bleiben vielleicht noch so 5000 übrig
ungefähr die größte sind Fledermäuse die
artenreichste Gattung der Tiere und wenn
man überhaupt auf Tiere guckt und fragt
was ist die artenreichste Gattung hat
seine Ahnung
Insekten ich innerhalb der Insekten
innerhalb der innerhalb der Insekten
gibt es eine die für sich allein schon
so an die eine Millionen Arten hat sind
auch nicht alle bekannt fliegen nee
Käfer Käfer ja also der liebe Gott hatte
eine irrsinnige Schwäche Verkehre und
jetzt gibt's natürlich die die die
Freunde der Spinnen Tiere die sagen ja
aber wenn es so viele Käfer gibt dann
muss es genauso viele Milben geben weil
es gibt eigentlich für jeden Käfer eine
spezifische Milbe die ihn umbringt die
nicht umbringen der aber die als Parasit
von ihm lebt okay genau
keine Insekten ja genauso wenig wie
Zecken sondern Spinnentiere und dass man
also sagen wenn die Milben sie noch viel
kleiner als die Käfer also davon gibt's
wahrscheinlich noch mehr als Käfer aber
von dem was man so sehen und anfassen
kann sind Käfer das häufigste in der
Welt anarten das heißt man muss davon
ausgehen wenn man nachts in so einem
Bett liegt auf so eine Matratze liegt
man ist nicht alleine
das sind sehr auf deine Haut sind auch
jetzt in diesem Leben
ich weiß ja Millionen Milliarden ja ja
ganz ganz gut gucken können es ist Sonne
Jörg Blech hat mal ein großartiges Buch
darüber kennst du bestimmt spiegelautor
der hat ja ganz viele Sachen zu dem
Thema geschrieben und der kleine das
auch guck lieber nicht so genau hin du
würdest Dich erschrecken genau oder die
Angst davor verlieren also man könnte
sich ja Mensch gewünscht sich auch an
alles ne also würde man irgendwie so
liebevolles Verhältnis zu sein Milben
aufbauen ja genau die man nicht sieht
als den Dingen die man sieht
also Mengen Menschen die sich
verschlangen oder so fürchten die
fürchten sich am meisten dafür wenn sie
in Afrika abends nachts im Zelt liegen
und gucken sozusagen dreimal in ihren
Schlafsack ja also die die Schlange die
man sieht die die kann man sich ja noch
eher drauf Einschalten die Schlange die
man nicht sieht die weiß ja ja ich wurde
von einer Schlange gebissen mal
lustigerweise nicht weit von Tasmanien
in Australien ja von einer Schlange die
sehr wohl zu sehen war ein brauner
Instanz
sagen nee du kennst doch die Brown Snake
ja und das ist eine der giftigsten
Schlange der Welt ja und es gibt eine
Anverwandte die Brown treesnake das ist
auf dem Baum ja die ist sehr giftig aber
nicht so giftig wäre Verwandte auf dem
Boden und die hat mich gebissen ich war
mit einem Mann unterwegs der der die
fängt und dieses Gift zu gewinnen und
die Aufgabe war mit weil wir heute video
podcast machen kann man das mal ganz
kurz zeigen mit so du hast so einen Sack
ja immer so über den Unterarm ja und
dann gehst du hin und packst also mit
der Hand im Sack ja
ist in diesem packst du die Schlange
hinten am naschen genau so genau und und
für die großen Arten hast ja so eine Art
Zange und das war aber die ist nicht
sehr groß nur so so sehr dünn und sieht
aber auch sehr giftig aus und ich ich
fast dahin todesmutig und ich hatte
richtig Manschetten und weil ich solche
Mannschaften habe ich ich war nicht weit
oben weit genug oben am Kopf und dadurch
zieht den den Beutel rüber und habe der
Schlange die Chance gegeben sich in
diesem Beutel umzudrehen Kopf umzudrehen
und dann spürte ich plötzlich hier in
diesem Finger oder sich nicht so langsam
so immer tiefer rein immer tiefer
reindeckte
so eine kleine Rasierklinge und
interessant ist bei dieser Brownies die
hat die Zähne nicht vorne die hinten
sitzt sehr sehr tief hinten genau der
sich so langsam da rein und man konnte
das richtig spüren ich hatte hier so
sehr kleine Einstiche aber wie war fast
eine Woche schlecht von diesem fremden
Eiweiß das plötzlich in meinem Körper
aber Vögel die die Vogel fressenden
Schlangen haben ihre giftszene ganz
hinten okay ja tritt dieser ganze
Bereich der trug knattern und so weiter
zu ne die die das ist eine entspannende
Geschichte ne die brauchen also die
Vorderzähne quasi nur zum Festhalten und
nur mit den hinteren hat das Gift ihn
jetzt hier interessant ja genau anders
als bei einer Kobra ne die zwei große
hier vorne hat oder bei den klassischen
Vipern gruppen-ottern die hier so etwas
an der Seite sondern hat interessante
bei der Geschichte das war für eine
Fernseher Reportage und ich ich war
natürlich als junger Reporter ich war
wahnsinnig stolz darauf jetzt dieses
spektakuläre Material zu haben bei der
Ausreise habe ich dann festgestellt war
nicht mehr da und erst wurde mir erzählt
Kamera hat leider nicht aufgenommen ich
habe dann hinterherfahren der ist
einfach gelöscht sofort gelöscht panisch
Angst hatten dass ich eine
Multimillionen Dollar
klarheitsgeschichte eine Woche eine
Woche so ein bisschen so so übel wie die
Reise Übelkeit
Nervengift genau ja im Gegensatz zu wenn
jetzt von der Fieber gebissen wirst ja
also irgendeiner von den dicken und
gefährlicheren und so weiter und dann
wird das ja erst grau dann blau und dann
irgendwann schwach sowas ne da steigt ja
so ganz ganz langsam hoch und da der
beste Mittel ist Amputation
bei Giftnattern natürlich nicht
ich habe so eine Situation gegen Gift
bekommen okay meine ich mich zum hat
sich dann so eine Woche mulmig gefühlt
ja ja nicht mulmig sondern mir war
schlecht ja wirklich schlecht ich habe
diese diese dieses fremde Protein dass
du deinen Körper hast das merkst du
einfach Nein ist fremde Eiweiß ja aber
eigentlich häufig zur Atem Lähmungen
[Musik]
die stellen sich auch manchmal als 30
Jahre später 30 Jahre später
das könnt ihr das Thema sein aber
Richard sagt Artenvielfalt ne ich weiß
ich hatte öfter Gespräch interessante
Gespräche mit dir Steffens liebe Grüße
an der Stelle der immer wieder sagte in
der Sendung und das ist mir
hängengeblieben und deswegen würde ich
so gerne mal heute mit dir darüber reden
Klimawandel
ist etwas worüber wir reden müssen und
wir alle merken es ja gerade auch wieder
in diesem Sommer was da gerade passiert
aber er sagte das viel größere was
gerade stattfindet und die eigentliche
Katastrophe ist das Verschwinden der
Arten wie verlieren offenkundig jeden
Tag 150 Arten
das heißt die Biodiversität geht
verloren wobei das zum großen Teil
natürlich jetzt hatten sind die wir noch
gar nicht kennen genau
einen anderen Frosch richtig ne also in
der andere Art meistens sehr sehr kleine
so Plattfische und sowas also das ist
sowas was wir verschwinden was wir zum
Teil gar nicht entdeckt haben ja sehr
selten richtig große Tiere aus
ja und also ist in der Geschichte
passiert ja in Freiheit ausgeschoben war
der Wiesend oder die weiße orix Antilope
oder sowas aber die werden heute also
wenn sie besonders schön aussehen und
besonders attraktiv sind und viele Fans
haben und so im Regelfall ja recht gut
in Restbeständen genau
sibirische Tiger sogar mal angefasst das
ist ihre die die reagieren auf auf
Zucker ich habe mal der Reportage über
sibirische Tiger gedacht armutiger die
die lieben Zucker Sahne wenn du ein
armutiger mit Sahne anlockst der der
springt ich weiß noch ich saß oben
Podest und hatte diese Sahne Dose in der
Hand und die wussten genau was da drin
ist und dann geht der von unten so an
und dann siehst Du dieses mächtige Tiere
sind ja unfassbar schöne
majestätische Tiere und macht sich so
bereit zum Sprung und dachte oh Gott das
nächste was in diesem Haus verschwindet
bist du aber nicht an mir war nur an der
Seine Dose interessieren
dass das gesund ist für den Tiger aber
das ein anderer das ist eine andere
Frage ja ja das war war auch so eine so
eine lange her ne aber was Dirk damals
sagte das fand ich so interessant und
dir wenn die Arten verschwinden dann
kann es sein dass wir irgendwann als
Menschheit ein echtes Problem kriegen
und der Punkt ist ich habe den dann
gefragt ob wir so ein Panda verschwindet
immer das wäre schade es wäre traurig
wir alle lieben Panda aber nicht schlimm
genau wäre nicht schlimm ja aber
Beispiel Haie sieht die Welt schon
anders aus Haie fressen Barracudas und
die wiederum fressen Papageienfische ja
und die wiederum fressen Algen ja die
auf der Koral sitzen exakt die berühmte
Seerose so ja das heißt wenn du jetzt
den Hai da oben wegnimmst den Topf
Beutejäger ja ja dann vermehren sich die
Barracudas ja die werden nicht mehr
gefressen dann vermehren die sich so
weit dass der Papageienfisch
verschwindet und dann ist niemand mehr
da
der die Koralle von der Alge befreit so
einfach dann haben eine der Ursachen des
Coral Bleaching zum Beispiel genau diese
winzigen kleinen Tiere die da die auf
diesen Korallen Leben und da und wenn du
das dann so hörst merkst oder das so
alles klar das ist ja Zusammenhang so
eine ganz klassische Kette und er sagte
und das war sozusagen die beunruhigende
Nachricht er meinte weißt du man weiß
nie genau welches Wesen welche Art den
ganzen Laden zusammenhält das heißt wir
können uns eigentlich auf das Experiment
egal ob das oder jenes verschwindet
können uns eigentlich nicht einlassen
weil wir nicht wissen ob wir diese Art
irgendwann brauchen vielleicht ist es
dann genau das eine Lebewesen dass uns
irgendwann das Antibiotikum gebracht
hätte um vielleicht das nächste Virus in
Griff zu verfeinern Bakterien zwei große
Überlegung
also das eine ist meistens sind die
Tiere die uns besonders am Herzen liegen
wahrscheinlich die ökologisch am
wenigsten wichtig
also der sogenannte sibirische Tiger was
soll dem passieren wenn ihr sibirische
Tiger die paar hundert die da noch in
der Tiger von sich Schote Aline leben
wenn die verschwinden Wildschweinen
Überpopulation dass deren Haupt Beute
oder zu viele Hirsche die Gefahr besteht
nicht ernsthaft dafür sind ja jetzt
schon viel viel zu wenige Tiger da also
oder wenn die Wale aus dem Meeren
verschwinden was wäre dann
wahrscheinlich nicht so wahnsinnig
Probleme im Ernst jetzt nee auch nicht
große Jäger ja und was soll denn
passieren zu viele Robben die müssen ja
wiederum auch Ihre Fische fressen und so
weiter das glaube ich nicht also das
sieht ja immer die Tiere die ganz am
Ende der Nahrungskette sind
und natürlich würde ich nicht sagen ist
hinterlässt gar keine Spuren aber es
wird wahrscheinlich nicht dramatisch
werden
es gibt so dass dieser ökologischen
großdiskussion 70er 80er 90er Jahre gab
es immer die Frage als dass du losgehen
mit der wir gucken wie muss man sich die
Natur vorstellen also mal gesetzentwall
die Natur ist ein Flugzeug und dann gab
es so die die Vorstellung jedes Tier und
jede Pflanze ist irgendein miet und dass
dieses Flugzeug zusammenhält und wenn
irgendein Lied an irgendeiner Stelle
nicht mehr funktioniert ja dann kannst
du eine Kettenreaktion geben und stürzt
das Flugzeug ab das Theorie eins
Theorie 2 ist dass sie sagt ja ein Teile
sind die Nieten und anderen Teil sind
die blinden Passagiere ja und es können
unglaublich viele Arten ausgerottet
werden ohne dass es dramatische Folgen
für die Flugtüchtigkeit des Flugzeugs
hat und wahrscheinlich sind wir etwas
näher an Theorie zwei als ein Theorie
eins also sind Theorie eins ist so ein
bisschen der liebe Gott hat das so
geplant dass jeder ganz ganz genau an
seinem Platz und da darf keiner
weggenommen werden
und das ist eigentlich kryptometaphysik
ja also daran muss man sehr fest glauben
es ist fast eine verschwörungserzählung
so jetzt könnte man als Folge ja sagen
ach ja gut wenn es auch viele nicht
ankommt ja da macht ja auch die
Ausrottung viele Arten nicht aus jetzt
trete ich mit was ganz anderem auf dem
Plan als der Steffen der das
wahrscheinlich auch nachvollziehen kann
aber der anders argumentiert hat der
sagt warum müssen wir das alles immer
vom Nutzen des Menschen aus betrachten
das ist ein guter Punkt ja also für mich
ich meine ich finde es wahnsinnig schade
um jede Art die wir ausrotten weil ich
finde es so großartig dass die Welt voll
von Wesen ist die wir nicht geschaffen
haben die wir nicht manipulieren die
ohne uns da sind die vor uns nah waren
die noch nach uns da sein werden die uns
überhaupt nicht brauchen und ich bin ein
Mensch der davon total faszinierbar also
mich fasziniert das ist das alles gibt
also wir haben ja schon häufiger über
Religion geht ja ich bin ja er
pantheistisch also ich habe ja eine eine
ganz große
sozusagen ja nicht im Kitsch nee genau
aber ich habe halt ein ganz große
Ehrfurcht vor der Natur und eine ganz
hohe ästhetische Faszination und ob
dieser eine Greifvogel den ich so
wahnsinnig toll finde ich jetzt aus
ökologischen Gründen notwendig ist oder
nicht das ist die letzte Frage die ich
mir stelle wenn ich ihn toll und
faszinierend finde sein Verschwinden
finde ich genauso tragisch wenn die
Menschheit ihn nicht braucht ja klar ja
und ich finde wir müssen die Betrachtung
eher in diese Richtung dann dass Sie
diese nutzen Theorie die ist mir zu hart
das Versagen okay mein Klimawandel wir
müssen das und das und das machen weil
das ist schädlich das ist nützlich und
so weiter und jetzt gucken wir uns die
Biodiversität an und dann gucken wir
brauchen wir das hier brauchen wir dass
das kein Weg ja was ist wichtig was ist
ein wichtiges Lied wer ist blinder
Passagiere also überhaupt so eine
Betrachtungsweise auf die Natur finde
ich total aberisch also er zeigt sich
der Mensch von seiner übelsten Seite
dass man nur das braucht in der Natur
was wirklich ökologisch nützlich ist
ich verstehe den Gedanken ich meine so
ist es von von Dirk natürlich weiß ich
natürlich und auch ich wollte nur
erweitern genau dass diese Dimension ja
auch eine Rolle spielen ich glaube aber
dass sie wenn Politiker über Ökologie
nachdenken oder so gar keine Rolle
spielt sondern das ist dann eher
wirklich um die nutzen
kann sein ich meine du hast ja diese
Faszination für Vögel ne wenn dann dann
afrikanischer Kampfadler den ich ja das
Glück hatte zu fotografieren richtig
ja total stolz drauf ne also ein richtig
schönes ist doch bei Wikipedia jetzt ne
ja ja ja
einfach ein ganz normal in meinem Leben
was sinnvolles gemacht wirklich auch
sagen schön dass man sagen kann am Ende
was bleibt drauf das war ein reiner
Zufallstreffer ja ich sehe mich noch wie
ich diese ich hatte eine ich hatte einen
600 nee 800 mm Linse hatte ich dabei ja
so ein Ding ja und dann habe ich noch
ein Konverter drauf geschraubt das heißt
du verlängerst das noch mal du verlierst
ein bisschen Licht aber durch diesen
Konverter habe ich dann bin ich auf
1.200 mm gekommen es war irre viel und
dann so aus der Hand also und ein
scharfes Foto hingekriegt also ich kann
die nicht ich kann dir Leistung sehr
sehr genau beurteilen ich habe nicht
verstanden letztes Jahr einen Kampfadler
gesehen also malerisch mit Beute auf
einem Ast und habe den mit meiner Kamera
fotografiert und äh habt ihr dann an
gute Freunde die sich mit dem Thema auch
beschäftigen stolz geschickt weil ich
habe das ja nur so kleine Display
gesehen und gesagt vielleicht kannst das
ein bisschen bearbeiten und so weiter
ich muss sagen ein sehr lausiges Volk
aber es bleibt ein großer Moment also
dadurch
ein Thema Arten ne da kommt man ja ganz
schnell kommt man zu darin
ich fand interessant doch bis
zum Auftauchen von David ja war
eigentlich doch so die Idee das hat
alles
was göttlich ist das hat Gott gemacht
jede Art von Anfang an geschaffen und
seitdem ist nichts mehr dazu gekommen
und auch nichts mehr weggekommen nicht
ganz sondern nicht ganz also vor den
Engländern war die Evolutionstheorie
eine Sache der Franzosen okay und da gab
es zwei bedeutende Franzosen der eine
war George
war der Goethe ja für für die Tiere die
Lebenden und eben auch die
ausgestorbenen man hat in der Zeit
Dinosaurierknochen gefunden
und dieser schorscht muss also war der
Chef Archäologe oder parallel und
verlogen wir reden von ähm um das Jahr
zwischen 1800 und 183 okay also darwin
war noch nicht auf dem Plan gedreht der
war geboren aber noch nicht also der
wurde in der Zeit geboren das heißt also
deutlicher Generation später genau und
dieser Schauspieler war also
Wissenschaftsmanager und top Forscher in
einer Person also ganz große Nummer der
diese Dinger plant aufgebaut hat das
Musee ist zwar natürlich Museum die
Forschungsinstitution für Natur
schlechthin in der Welt
und der hatte die Theorie aufgestellt
okay es hat die Tiere gegeben die ist
nicht mehr gibt Dinosaurier und er war
derjenige der diese ganzen Dinosaurier
als erster bestimmt und klassifiziert
hat und er war ein so großer Experte
dass man also sagte gibt irgendein
Knochen von irgendeinem Känguru ja und
der guckt da drauf und sagt nach einer
Sekunde Känguru Knochen also war der
absolute Experte aber der hatte ein
Problem mit der Vorstellung dass die
Arten sich sukzessiv verändert haben
sollen denn das haben zu seiner Zeit
zwei andere behauptet
leer und lamarek das heißt er hatte zwei
Mitarbeiter in seiner Institution die
fest davon überzeugen sind dass die
Arten sich verändern
beide hatten dafür aber keine restlos
überzeugende Theorie okay und Cuvier
vertrat den Zeitpunkt solange die
Theorie Schwachstellen hat bleiben wir
beim alten Modell falls Duplikation das
war auch weltanschaulich wichtig mein
Mann hatte sehr lange nicht weil er so
religiös war er hat zwar nachher auch so
ein Amt da gekriegt aber als Protestant
sondern weil das so eine
gesellschaftliche Dynamik freisetzt das
hat die Evolutionstheorie auch gemacht
alles ist im Fluss alles ist veränderbar
Gesellschaft kann auch ganz anders sein
und so weiter ja klar und das hat ja
später eine riesen Rolle gespielt sozial
Darwinismus und so wie im Tierreich so
im Menschenrecht und diesen Sack den
wollte der zulassen und deswegen hat er
diese anderen Theorien bekämpft aber die
der Gedanke dass die Arten sich
verändern der war so Anfang des 19
Jahrhunderts schon richtig irgendwo
interessant ja und als als darin auf dem
Plan trat weiß nicht völlig neu das zu
denken sondern das schwierige war jetzt
Beweise
der fertigen die besser waren als bei
der vorhergehenden Theorie weil Lamarck
hat er gesagt die Arten haben im Laufe
der Evolution quasi gelernt
die Giraffe hat Anstrengungen gemacht wo
man die Blätter ranzukommen ja und diese
anstrengungsimpuls von Genetik hatte man
keine Ahnung aber der hat sich vererbt
klar auf die nächste Generation und auf
diese Art und Weise im Laufe der Zeit
wurden die Hälse der Giraffen immer
länger ja dass also die Mühen das ist
etwas was heute nicht mehr ganz so
unsinnig ist als was es lange gesehen
wird seit wir über Epigenetik reden und
so Umwelteinflüsse Sachen Lernerfahrung
können ja möglicherweise indirekt doch
vielleicht vererbt werden es ist nicht
ganz großer Quatsch aber so wie das da
radikal formuliert worden war was nicht
zu beweisen ich weiß doch hat mir das
mal so erklärt und meinte weißt du
Evolution ist kein Plan Evolution ist
Zufall Evolution probiert einfach raus
und wenn sich eine Art reproduziert dann
kommen immer wieder neue
Exemplare sozusagen auf die Welt und
alle sind ein bisschen anders natürlich
wieder Zufall ist will ja merkt man auch
unseren Kindern genau
und wenn eine bestimmte Fähigkeit
gefragt ist du brauchst ein besonders
langen Schnabel für irgendwas du
brauchst ein besonders langen Hals dann
setzt sich diese Fähigkeit so langsam
aber sicher durch
die einfache Idee das ist die sehr
einfache Idee und ich glaube die Sache
ist komplizierter ja weil welche Rolle
spielt in dem Zusammenhang David
Galapagos das erzähle ich gleich also
auf den Vorteil kommt es nur direkt an
erstmal weiß man häufig bei vielen
Dingen nicht ob sie sich langfristig als
vorteilhaft erweisen aber ich glaube es
funktioniert umgekehrt jeder Scheiß
überlebt
solange er nicht zum Aussterben führt
okay er muss keinen Vorteil haben ja ein
nicht tödlicher Nachteil überlebt auch
also wenn wir uns erklären wollen warum
hat dieser Hirsch das und das Geweih und
der hat das und warum hat der Hirsch
Ebers und Schwein auf Zähne besser und
komisch konkreten Spazierstock als als
auch mit dem man nicht kämpfen
imponieren drohen gar nichts kann weil
das gerade einfach genau weil weiß nicht
gestört hat weiß nicht zum Aussterben
geführt wird unser Gehirn ist ja
unverhältnismäßig groß im Vergleich zu
vielen anderen Arten ne und das war ja
relativ sinnlos glaube ich lange Zeit ne
also also
diese Theorien die die die allem jetzt
immer ein ganz genauen Sex zu denken
Mensch aber die Evolution funktioniert
nicht so aber welchen Sinn soll es haben
ein größeres Gehirn zu entwickeln für
dass du 25% deiner Energie brauchst wenn
du doch in der Savanne unterwegs bist
und es auf jede Kalorie ankommt ja das
macht eigentlich keinen Sinn anderer
Affen haben das ja auch nicht genau
wahnsinnig schwer diese hypertrophierung
des Neocortex ja ähm genau
und das ist der Bereich für unsere
höheren kognitiven Leistungen
untergebracht hier vorne genau
also nicht nur ganz vorne aber
jedenfalls im vorderen Teil also nicht
hier hinten tief ja wir stammen und
Kleinhirn sitzen super genau ja und also
ich glaube nicht dass man das immer
unter dem Gesichtspunkt ja das war total
nützlich dafür und das war zweckmäßig
und deswegen konnte man und so konnte
sich der Mensch und dann ausbreiten und
so das klingt ja immer noch so als wenn
dann Plan hinter ist ne und da hat
Steffens natürlich völlig recht das
überhaupt kein Plan hinter und wie
gesagt jeder Scheiß überlebt solange
nicht zum Aussterben führt ich habe mit
auf dem Weg können wir die Vielfalt
diese enorme Artenvielfalt von der wir
gar nicht wissen wie große überhaupt ist
ne es gibt die schätzt 8 Millionen Arten
ja das stimmt Lieblingszahl und bekannt
sind ungefähr zwei Millionen ja genau
die Leute die das entziffern können das
wird keiner mehr also Taxonomie ist ja
die Lehre ja von der Klassifikation
genau so erkennen ob diese Motte neu ist
oder nicht muss ich alle anderen Motten
gehen so jetzt gibt's aber zigtausende
von Motten Daten oder bei Käfern es gibt
ein immer weniger Experten in der Welt
die überhaupt erkennen können ob sie
sich um eine neue Tierart handelt oder
nicht bei Säugetieren noch einfach bei
Vögeln auch noch einfach ja aber bei
Insekten diese Leute sterben aus die
sterben mit den Insekten aus
sonst kommen die auch Arten dazu davon
musst du noch ausgehen wenn Evolution
einfach immer weiter sich ausprobieren
ist
wobei das meistens recht lange dauert
aber stimmt es gibt natürlich auch Tiere
wo Evolutionen unterschiedlich schnell
und langsam geht also ein Beispiel dafür
naja also Eisbären sind nicht alt
betrachtet nicht alt also da gehen die
Meinung auch auseinander ja aber da gab
es schon Menschen möglicherweise über
zwei Eisbär entstanden ist also der gibt
es keine einheitliche Theorie war ja
keiner dabei aber die Veränderung dass
der Vorfahre also ein bauen wäre also
ein Grizzly oder kodia oder so also
solche Frauen werden die im Norden leben
sich da in die arktischen Gegebenheiten
angepasst haben kleinen Kopf kriegten
kleine Ohren kriegten etwas andere
Proportionen und so weiterhaut ja
schwarzer Haut ja Luft Luft luftprozent
in der Luft sehr kurzer Zeit sich
vollzogen hat so wie es ja umgekehrt bei
Eisbären gerade geht ne die du kennst
die kakaobären oben gerade gerade in der
Ecke tobik da oben Nordalaska paaren
sich Eisbären immer häufiger mit den
großen grauen Bär braun werden weil das
jetzt offensichtlich in Zeiten Schwinden
der Eismassen einen Vorteil bringen und
du siehst daran dass das genetische
Möglichkeit das eigentlich dürfte es ja
gar nicht gehen also wäre der Eisbär so
keine saubere Art dürfte er sich mit dem
Braunbär nicht mehr parken dass der
Punkt da unterscheidet man
ja das wird nie ernst genommen aber
klassisch hat man mal gesagt ne
innerhalb einer Art ist das was ich
innerhalb einer Art vermehrt und was ich
mit anderen keine fruchtbaren Nachkomme
macht das ist dann eine andere Art also
die Frage wäre wenn er ist wenn der
Braunbär sicheren kriegen die fertile
Nachfahren okay also du kannst Löwen und
Tiger miteinander fahren das geht das
geht ja da kommt dann gibt's tausend
Namen die Liga Gelaber heraus okay aber
die können sich ihrer die können sich
nicht okay
das gleiche ist ja wenn wenn Pferd und
Esel sich miteinander fahren und da
kommt ja je nachdem wer Mutter oder
Vater ist entweder ein Maul Esel ja oder
ein Maultier dabei raus genau und die
sind ihrerseits die können die sich
untereinander nicht vermehren
interessant okay ich bringe die vom
Thema Frechheit also David ja ja das
berühmte Schiff die Expedition nach
Galapagos ja was was ist sozusagen die
die Bedeutung von von Charles Darwin ja
also die ist sehr häufig falsch erzählt
deswegen freue ich mich dass wir die
Gelegenheit gibst diese großartige
Geschichte mal zu erzählen also ist
nicht als Naturforscher auf dieses
Schiff gegangen als junger Mann also er
hatte ein Theologiestudium
angefangen gemacht und ein äh ich glaube
erst mit Medizin angefangen und dann
konnte er keine Leichen und dann hat der
Theologie studiert aber seine große
Liebe galt der Natur also der kannte
sich auch gut aus mit der heimischen
Tier und Vogelwelt und so weiter und ist
dann auf dieses Schiff gekommen als
Gesellschaft das Kapitäns okay ja der
solche den späteren Admiral Fitzroy
unterhalten ne der sollte mit dem was
haben die Rist gespielt oder solche
Sachen oder Schach vielleicht oder sowas
unterwegs die waren unterwegs wie die
meisten Forschungsexpeditionen in der
damaligen Zeit wegen Landvermessung und
Bodenschätze das war das was
interessiert ne wo sind genau die Küsten
wo ist noch irgendwas zu holen wo könnte
es irgendwas geben und es gab übrigens
einen naturforsch er ein Wort der Bibel
der dafür zuständig war an den erinnert
sich keiner mehr
und Darwin hat sich für alles
interessiert was er da in Pflanzen
Tieren und so weiter sehen konnte und
das meiste davon auch gegessen
es war so eine schräge Passion von
Darwin Puma gegessen ja einfach ich weiß
nicht warum also er hat diese Tiere die
ja dir irgendwie spannend fand gegessen
und ich weiß dass die Abkehr kam als ein
Waldkauz gegessen hat das war das letzte
schräge Tier was er gegessen hat also
eine Eule muss unglaublich beschissen
wenn man sich so ein Gewölle von der von
so einer Eule die ja nachher heraus
wirkt was sie nicht verdauen kann ja
also Haare und Knochen und sowas anguckt
da hat meine Vorstellung glaube ich also
das ist also dass das überhaupt überlebt
hat war unglaublich schlechter danach
naja also das nur am Rande ja Leguane
gegessen Puma gegessen und so weiter und
er hat dann natürlich alles
aufgeschrieben was neu ist und so weiter
Museen zu geben
ne würde ich sagen wenn du Bayern ist ja
das brandgefährlich kannst du die
Trichine holen ja kennst du ich habe
noch keine Eisbären gegessen also ich
habe mal ein ganz kleines Stück gegessen
ne oder habe ich wenn du wenn du nicht
in der Lage bist in der Robbe zu essen
kommst irgendwo nicht weiter tatsächlich
wahlfleisch wahrscheinlich habe ich auch
probiert mag ich überhaupt gar nicht und
ich finde einen lebenden Wahl so viel
schöner als ein totenwald aber bei nicht
probiert habe ich probiert Eisbären
musst du auf Spitzbergen
musst du Stunden viele Stunden kochen um
diese Trichine das sind so Parasiten und
die wirklich loszuwerden wenn wir nicht
hast du ein Problem okay dann zerstören
dich von ihnen jetzt gleich
die Medizin der damaligen Zeit vor auf
explodieren ja also du bist ja ja
definitiv hat er gemacht ja also jemand
der für das Medizinstudium zu sensibel
war ja aber hatten genug aber so Kreise
mitzumachen man muss sich auch
vorstellen die anderen Leute auf dem
Schiff waren ja mehr so Passagiere ne
ich weiß ja heuerte auch solchen auf
solche langen Reisen an ja in dem
Zusammenhang nur ein kleiner Einschub
die die Expedition von Amundsen z.B ne
ja ich meine der hatte Anzeigen
geschaltet und hat gesagt pass auf ich
suche Leute die mir zum Nordpol fangen
was meinst wer sich da gemeldet hat die
gleichen Leute die in der Legion Wagner
kämpfen so genau solche Leute aus
Gefängnissen und so weiter und die
Expedition zum Südpol als es um den
Wettlauf zum Südpol ging haben uns gegen
Scott
der hatte die erstmal eingetütet in Oslo
alle eingesammelt raus auf der Frame
dieses berühmte Schiff mit mit dem
Qualitäten ja genau war so konstruiert
ne dass wenn das Eis sich
zusammenschiebt ganz flach dass ich das
Ding einfach so auf die eiskalt aber
allein lassen überlegt mal das ist ja
etwas das kannst du ja erst wissen ob es
funktioniert muss man probiert hast und
es gibt Nansen der ja vorher auf diesem
Schiff unterwegs war der hat das Bericht
es gibt wahnsinnig er kriege ich jetzt
noch Gänsehaut in Nacht und Eis dieses
Buch über die die Expedition der Frauen
war die Idee war zum Nordpol zu kommen
oder das erste Mal beschreibt wie
plötzlich dieses Schiff anfängt zu
knacken und alles klar und echt und du
denkst du wirst zusammengedrückt ja ja
und die die Idee war wie überwintern da
drin wir bleiben einfach da drin und
lassen uns sozusagen vom Treibhaus
einfach entspannt zum nordpolt Treiben
das war der Plan das musst du dich mal
trauen das ist vorstellbar und Amundsen
hat damals Weg zum Südpol dieses selbe
Schiff genommen wie jetzt der Eis
bewährt hat diese Leute eingesammelt und
als sie draußen waren auf offener sie
hat er denn gesagt übrigens wir fahren
nicht nach Norden geht jetzt mal zum
Südpolen
erstmal so flächenmäßig angenommen
ja ja also der der Böse in zwei
glorreichen hallo
und mein Gott also der hat hier ein
Gesicht mit dem meine Lokomotive
aufhalten hatte Typ hatte absolut aber
zurück zur guten Abend unsere Reise
so ein süßer Name wie viel für so einen
Expeditionsschiff
und er war unter anderem auf den
Galapagosinseln und dann hat er
natürlich auch diese verschiedenen
Schildkröten gesehen und auf diese Art
auf den anderen Inseln Finken ja die
alle unterschiedlich aussah und hier
beginnt die Legende
Darwin wusste natürlich nicht dass diese
ganzen Vögel die er da sorgfältig
geschossen ja und als belge sortiert hat
und wo manche lange Schnäbel hatten und
andere kurzen und manche Werkzeuge
gebrauchten und andere nicht und so
weiter dass das alles finden waren die
voneinander Abstanden da hat er auch
kein Riecher oder keine Eingabe gehabt
ich meine wenn man sich schon mit der
gesamten Vogelwelt Englands auskennt als
junger Mann dann weiß man schon sehr
viel dann kann man aber nicht in
Südamerika auf den Inseln die Vögel
sofort bestimmen und weiß dass das
finden sind das ist eine ganz große
Legende der hat das also alles gesammelt
und dann hat er also zurück kam das im
damaligen wer war das Naturhistorische
Museum noch mit dem Britischen Museum
zusammen den zuständigen Vogelexperten
gegeben schon gut dann ganz berühmter
Vogel Maler war ja und der
ornithologisch schlechthin und der hat
ihn
mühseligster kleinen Arbeit ja bewiesen
dass das alles finden sind was dann zu
der Folge führt dass sie sich abhängig
davon
auf welcher Insel sie waren und so
weiter unterschiedlich entwickelt haben
also der eine das ist eine These die man
nur dann belegen kann wenn man genau
nachweisen kann dass das alles
Angehörige eine einzigen Vogelart oder
einer ursprünglichener Vogelfamilie sind
die sich dann zu verschiedenen Arten
entwickelt hat das konnte David nicht
wissen auf die rückwärts Theorie ist er
da nicht gekommen aber wie hat der das
gemacht ich meine damals noch heute
sagen wie DNA kannst du doch irgendwie
nachweisen
Morphologie heißt ja also vergleichende
Morphologie die hatten ja damals schon
eine große Vogelsammlung auch aus Vögeln
aus Indonesien und von aller Welt die
haben die Schubladen voll mit Vögeln
gehabt und dann vergleichst du das damit
und guckst du nach übereinstimmenden
Merkmal okay das war das heute Anfang
der Taxonomie ist ist bei bei Pflanzen
gab es gibt so Merkmale wie ist der
Stempel angeordnet und durch die Blüte
untersucht und das Blatt da gab es so
Kriterien und so genau so in der
uniologie auch kannst also sogar
Ähnlichkeiten also bestimmt super so ist
aber da bin ich auf die
Evolutionstheorie gekommen
sondern das war für ihn nachher ein
super Beweis okay ja auf die also das
hat geholt erforscht Darwin ist hat
nachdem er zurückkam sehr sehr viel
gelesen weil er so dieser Gedanke mit
der Veränderung der lag in der Luft aber
wie gesagt durch die Franzose
und dann liest er ein Buch von einem
populärautor
über das Leben und das Werk von Adam
Smith und Adam Smith war ja der große
Philosoph von Nationalökonom gewesen der
den Kapitalismus als erster positiv
begründet hat indem er gesagt hat diese
berühmte Satz der Bäcker backt seine
Brötchen nicht weil ein guter Mensch ist
ja sondern weil er überleben will aber
es ist gut für die Gesellschaft das ist
Bäcker gibt
und die können ja nicht alle Bäcker sein
sondern einer muss ja auch Klempner sein
und einer muss Schumacher sein und
ansonsten Bauern sein und so entsteht
jetzt sozusagen in biologischer
Terminologie ein diversifiziertes Biotop
ja das Biotop der bürgerlichen
Gesellschaft klar und da strebt jeder
nach seinem Vorteil nach seinem Egoismus
heute sein genetischen Vorteil oder so
ne von jedem wusste auch David noch
nichts aber jeder will überleben ne
Trubel for Life und auf diese Art und
Weise spezifiziert sich die Gesellschaft
so etwas was wo überall gibt es Niesen
ja Märkte wo jemand reingeht und so und
da sagte sich darin ist das in einer
Natur nicht wie in der bürgerlichen
Gesellschaft er überträgt den
Kapitalismus jeder kämpft für sich und
am Ende entsteht ein großes Biotop auf
die Natur und das war der Gedanke und
was ist der Mechanismus dazu die
natürliche Selektion also der erfolglose
Geschäftsmann stirbt aus entweder
verhungert oder setzt sich nicht durch
oder nach was anderes und der
erfolgreiche setzt sich durch und in der
Natur gibt es das gleiche natürliche
Selektion und wer sich an den Markt am
besten anpasst überlebt am besten im
Kapitalismus und wer sich am besten in
der Natur anpasst überlebt am
langfristigsten eben auch in der Natur
das heißt der Kapitalismus wird auf die
Natur übertragen und dann kommt schon
gut und präsentiert ihm dass das alles
Finken sind wo sie jetzt völlig klar ist
die müssen also ursprünglich waren die
Inseln mal zusammen aus einer Art
entstanden sein und dann hat er ein
super Beweis also die da wo die Kapitel
ja genau da entsteht da wo die ja aber
das Wasser war wahrscheinlich niedriger
eine Finkenart dann gegen die Inseln
alle auseinander die sahen dann
vegetativ unterschiedlich aus auf dem
einen waren Kakteen auf der anderen gab
es ein bisschen mehr Bäume die anderen
warenkag und die finden haben deine
Anpassung an die Lebensräume haben sich
die durchgesetzt dieser am besten
angepasst war interessant also das
Spannende ist eben nicht äh der Junge
David erkennt dass das alles finden sind
und begründet so die Evolutionstheorie
sondern Evolutionstheorie die Darwinsche
entsteht durch die Übertragung
der Spielregeln des Kapitalismus auf die
Natur spannend das passt insofern als
der hat ja sehr sehr lange gewartet
irgendwie sein berühmtes Buch weil die
Artenvielfalt veröffentlicht hat die
waren ja schon 20 Jahre wieder zu Hause
ja nach 20 Jahren traut er sich also ich
stelle mir das musste er musste er stand
unter enormen Druck und zwar deswegen
überlege mal in der Zeit damals noch
sehr religiös geprägt ja victorianische
England genau man wollte sich mit der
Kirche nicht anlegen die Idee dass 4000
und 4 glaube ich ja ja mal ausgerechnet
hat die Bibel um sich mal genau
vorgeknöpft hat und sich gesagt hat wie
alt ist eigentlich die Welt so 4000 und
4 Jahre alt und da ist alles entstanden
in dieser in dieser einen berühmten
Woche bzw am Sonntag am Sonntag war
danach
ist also lamak weil
Millionen hat hier sein vorgängerprüfung
mit hunderttausenden von Jahren also die
die Fachwelt wusste alles
aber der ist wieder dasselbe Problem ja
du brauchst viel bessere Beweise als die
Gegenseite wenn du ein
gesellschaftliches Vorurteil kennen
willst überleg doch mal was das heißt du
und deswegen kann ich mir das so gut
vorstellen und zögerst 20 Jahre bist du
dieses Buch schreibst weil du sagst oh
lass mich nie fertig geschrieben wenn er
nicht ein Problem gekriegt hätte nämlich
das Problem ist Alfred Russell Wales
Alfred Russell Wallace war ein Junge aus
ernstem Hause der den Beruf ergriff
museumsammler zu werden auch also Hasan
mäßig in
abgelegene Gegenden zu fahren selber
zuerst in Südamerika da auch Tiere
zusammen ja also kurz nach Darwin da
gewesen Tiere gesammelt und so weiter um
die dann an die
naturhistorische Museen in Paris und in
London und so weiter zu verkaufen also
ein Händler mit toten Tieren quasi und
um das zu sein musstest du dich gut
auskennen klar das heißt ja als
Autodidakt hatte der eine tolle
Naturbilder Amerika war ihm seine ganze
Fracht bei der Überfahrt
und dann hat er eine zweite Reise
gemacht nach Indonesien und da gibt es
heute noch die berühmte wallacea yo
alles sehr ist die Grenze zwischen der
asiatischen und der australischen Welt
okay er hat also erkannt das ist eine
Tiergruppe gibt nur in der australischen
Welt vorkommt wenn einige mit Inseln die
dazugehören also Neuguinea und
Neuseeland und so weiter und genau
gezeigt wo die Grenze liegt zur
asiatischen Tierwelt
spezialisiert auf Schmetterlinge und
vieles andere mehr der kriegt da Malaria
und in einem malariaanfall zwischen zwei
Malaria anfällt bringt er auf zwei
Seiten seine autodidaktischen Gedanken
zu Papier warum ist diese Artenvielfalt
gibt und schreibt darin den essential
david ist er irre auf zwei Seiten die
Theorie der natürlichen Selektion das
woran darf ihn seit über 20 Jahren
basteln Wahnsinn und schickt diesen
Brief an David
und der kriegt das jetzt in der mit
Heizung kalt weil er sagt
genau das auf den Punkt gebracht woran
ich seit 20 Jahren arbeite und natürlich
noch den lückenlose Beweiskette und auch
den Beweis und den Beweis war in dieser
Zeit immer bei den Züchtern unterwegs
bei den Taubenzüchtern weil die
Taubenzüchter verändern die Arten doch
auch
die machen das was die Natur macht also
wenn du aus einer grauen Taube eine
weiße mit einem Schopf draus machst dann
suchst du doch aus deinen Tauben
diejenige raus die haben ja oder schon
bisschen
stellst du die immer weiter zusammen und
dann lässt du die so lange untereinander
kreuzen und das ist doch der Beweis für
die Veränderlichkeit der Arten klar das
läuft doch das selber ab nur dass die
Natur ja ähm kein Mensch ist klar
deswegen heißt ja das Buch über die
Entstehung der Arten durch naturliche
Zuchtwahl okay ja also die die lange
lange ja ja spannend und jetzt kriegt er
diesen Brief von Wallace und dann geht
er zur er würdigen liniens das hat die
ja und sagt ich habe ein Problem ich
arbeite da seit 20 Jahren ist das alle
und guckt euch das mal an wie gehen wir
damit um
und dann haben die gesagt wir machen
eine Sonderveröffentlichung da machst du
schreibst du jetzt mal die Quintessenz
deiner Gedanken und so weiter rein und
das drucken wir und parallel dazu
drucken wir auf der anderen Seite diesen
Wolles Brief wahnsinn das Buch ne ich
ich habe das mir noch mal angesehen ist
total interessant erscheint glaube ich
1859 im Mai und hat eine Auflage
starterauflage von glaube ich 1250 oder
1300 Stück sofort am ersten Tag
vergriffen also du siehst da liegt ein
Thema wirklich in der Luft und wenn du
verstehen willst welche
david hatte vor der Veröffentlichung
musst du nur in seine Tagebücher gucken
da steht der Satz mir ist als würde ich
einen Mord da stehen
da hatte einer richtig schlechtes
Gewissen aber
höchste Zeit dass das jetzt
veröffentlich ja und es ist ein
schwieriges Buch ja und es ist ein ein
Buch in dem er zum Beispiel etwas macht
was
wahnsinnig auffällig daran ist er wendet
es nicht auf den Menschen an sie hatte
ein so schlechtes Gewissen und so viel
Angst dass er in der Entstehung der
Arten nichts über die Menschen
geschrieben hat bis auf einen Satz ja
ganz am Ende des Buches sagte und von
all dem was ich hier geschrieben habe
wird auch Licht auf den Menschen fallen
spannend Wahnsinn mehr hat er sich nicht
gekauft so und dann hat sein Freund
Thomas Henry hacksley ja bekannt als
Darwins Bulldogge der ist in der
Öffentlichkeit in den Ring gestiegen und
hat mit dem Bischof der amerikanischen
Kirche Samos sich gebettelt ja in einem
Gerichtssaal Wahnsinn ja und diese rüber
vor gut ja also der hat doch den Finger
in Wunden oder ein Problem mit der
Theorie und so weiter gelegt und so
weiter der sieht die hatten sich
verdient wo ist der wo ist das
angreifbar
naja Beweislage das ist ein
indizienbereich klar und will aber Faust
bringt das dann auf den Punkt und sagt
okay müsste Darwin will uns verweisen
dass der Mensch von dem Pilzen abstammt
und so weiter ja so nach der Motte der
wie ich es doch so unendlich weit also
wenn das alles ganz ganz von Anfang an
und so weiter das läuft nicht und
umgekehrt ist Thomas Henry für damalige
Zeit bahnbrechen brutal mit dem Bischof
umgegangen also Angst los ja und hat ihn
da fertig gemacht und sich darüber
lustig gemacht und wir ab ständig und
rückständig und das in einer Zeit in der
nun tatsächlich gemacht hat für 90% der
Menschen sicher an Gott geglaubt haben
und in die Kirche gegangen aber ist das
nicht ganz nur ganz kleine Einschub aber
total interessanter Anknüpfungspunkt
sozusagen an die Aktualität ist es nicht
unfassbar schade dass wir diese Art auch
hart ja debattieren ja uns zu streiten
ja es uns richtig zu geben ja dass wir
das so dermaßen verlieren gerade als
ständig eine beleidigt ist aber oder
alle sich darüber entrüsten ja und so
weiter also ich sag ja mal
zumindestens den wohl meinen den Streit
der auch mit harten Bandagen geführt
wird gerade eben so erschütternden
Seiten wie die die wir gegenwärtig haben
ist natürlich extrem wichtig dass wir
den haben und dass wir den ausfallen ja
jetzt kommt doch die letzte Pointe
hacksley schreibt dann das Buch ja über
die Abstammung des Menschen so Skelette
da rein ja gerade wurde der Gorilla
entdeckt der ganz ganz spät entdeckt
worden ist na erst in der 1850er Jahren
oder am Ende der 1840er Jahre und sagt
also dass unser nächster Verwandter das
haben damals alle geglaubt und hat
sozusagen gezeigt der Mensch dann
verlassen hat Darwin hat nichts dazu
gesagt interessant
181 12 Jahre nach der Entstehung der
Arten sein Buch über die Abstammung des
Menschen heraus
in einem Tonfall ja da ist der Großvater
der lehnt sich in seinem Schaukelstuhl
zurück und erzählt eine wohl meine
Geschichte woher die Pflanzen die Tiere
und die Engländer kommen
da wird das dann also so freundlich und
nett so ja so gar nicht streiten lustig
ja sondern wirklich so ne Opa erzählt
jetzt mal eine Geschichte ne das ist
doch großartig
sehr gut gemacht
weil darum geht es ja auch ne wenn du so
ein also nicht nur sozusagen das
Argument zu haben es geht auch darum das
Argument zu gewinnen ja und wie machst
du das im Grunde ist das eigentlich
sozusagen die Analogie zu zu dieser
wunderbaren Theorie die ja eigentlich
sagt
pass auf es geht gar nicht darum dass du
der Stärkste der der skrupellos ist der
der brutalste bist sondern es geht darum
dass du der smarteste bist dass du der
cleverste bist dass du dich am besten
anpasst das ist übrigens gut hast du das
sagst ja das ist schon häufiges
Missverständnis die Deutschen als die
Darwin übersetzt haben ja haben ein
Problem damit gehabt diese berühmte
formulierungs survival of die nicht von
Darwin stammt sondern von dem
Philosophen Herbert Spencer der sofort
Darwin in seinem System eingebaut hat ja
und darin hat erst in der späteren
Auflage diese formulierungs survival of
the fit ist eingebaut weil er dachte
dies schön ne die passt sehr gut für
mich rein die übersetzt mein fit das ist
der Punkt und da wurde natürlich
weltanschaulich das Überleben der
stärksten draus gemacht ja der
tapfersten und der härtesten und so
weiter oder der geeignetsten ja oder der
strebsamsten also ich habe mal in meiner
Bibliothek weil ich mich dafür
interessiert immer mal Zettel
reingemacht wo diese Formulierungen sind
und ich glaube ich habe 12 verschiedene
Übersetzung gefunden die alle irgendwie
Interesse geleitet
und diese diese Vorstellung der
tüchtigsten ein sehr häufiger
Übersetzung tüchtig ist man durch
Anstrengung das hat David nicht gesagt
ein kleines Spezies die durch eine
Mutation ein bisschen anders ist hat
sich angestrengt ab sozusagen absolut ja
jetzt wird der protestantische
Arbeitsbegriff auf die Natur los das
heißt jetzt passiert wie du siehst
folgendes Darwin überträgt die
kapitalistische Theorie in die Biologie
und die Gesellschaftstheoretiker
übertragen wieder die Biologie in ihre
Gesellschaft
und diese Vorstellung der rechte
stärkeren und das tapfersten erster
Weltkrieg Nazi Ideologie Rassenlehre und
Darwin hatte Angst gehabt dass er hier
ein Sack aufgemacht hat hat er ja auch
der gefährlich ist
voll das verstanden
aber er hatte nichts gegen die Kirche
weil er dachte gut die Kirche ist für
viele Leute wichtig gibt den Leuten
Seelen Heimat und so weiter ich will
ihnen das nicht nehmen
er hatte sogar erlitt unter Depressionen
ja er hatte das Gefühl er hat etwas
gesehen von dem er nicht weiß ob er den
anderen das eigentlich im vollem Umfang
zeigen so mir ist das für dich ein Mord
gestärkt genau und dieses Gefühl mit
diesem Wort hat ihn nicht verlassen und
die Angst vor dem missbrauchte
Evolutionstheorie den politisch
gesellschaftlichen er hat ihn immer
begleitet wird dass man sagen kann
darwin war kein david ist interessant ja
sondern er hat in seinem Buch über den
Menschen den Schwerpunkt auf die
kultivierten Eigenschaften des Menschen
gelegt die Fähigkeit zu Liebe zur
Familie Bindung die fähigkeitskunst und
Kultur das sind alles Sachen die ja ganz
groß herausgestrichen hat damit die
Pointe am Ende nicht ist der Mensch ist
eine Bestie
genau darauf wollte er nicht hinaus und
dafür hat er und das wird auch häufig
nicht gesehen der Mechanismus des ersten
Bandes survival of the fittest den haben
wir beschrieben was ist denn der
Mechanismus bei Menschen dann greift
survival of the fittest gar nicht nee
Null warum greift das nicht weil die
entscheidendste Frage bei Menschen ist
nicht viel stark und wie Smart du bist
sondern wie viele Kinder du kriegst im
biologischen Sinne der vierteste ist der
der die meisten Lebens tauglichen
Nachkommen hat die sich wiederum
vermehren dass
am breitesten Seite ernähren ja und du
musst vor allen Dingen eine Frau
gewinnen und dann schreibt er in dem
Buch über den Menschen Monat Seiten über
die Vögel ja wie der Frau sein Rad
schlägt und der Leier auf Vogel und der
Paradiesvogel Beizen und so weiter und
er sagt die Fähigkeit zu Kunst und
Kultur sind eben entstanden weil wir
hier in einer Mechanismus haben nicht
die natürliche Selektion sondern die
sexuelle Selektion
die sexuelle Selektion hat andere
Spielregeln um dich dadurch zu setzen
musst du charmant sage ich ihm ein guter
Familienvater und so weiter und darauf
hat er den großen Schwerpunkt um diesen
bestienen Charakter darauf zu kriegen
spannend weißt du was das macht gerade
so Laune wir machen einen zweiten Teil
davon genau über dieses Weltbild und
sexuelle Evolution nicht Revolution und
kommen am Ende zurück passt doch
wunderbar zusammen
[Musik]
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und potsdas
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]